good morning a sky news investigation
has found
almost 10 000 vulnerable children in
care have been placed in potentially
unsafe and
unregulated accommodation that's
including caravans
tents and barges the care of young
people is in crisis partly due to a
national shortage
of children's homes councils have relied
on
unregulated accommodation as a way of
housing vulnerable children
but now the government says it will ban
the use of these settings for under 16s
but campaigners say it's not enough as
our people and politics correspondent
nick martin reports
my life should not be made up of
mistakes that were out of my control
ashley was just 15 when social services
had to find her a place to live
they sent her to a caravan she had
support staff
around the clock who were meant to look
after her
there was an incident
um a couple walked in to our caravan
and they'd been making home-brewed
alcohol
so i'd drank it and some of the staff
had as well i'd had about two or three
drinks
and i started to feel like i was about
to pass out which was not normal for me
at that point like
and i heard them shut the door and lock
it and i just i knew something wasn't
right
i took my chance and i ran i felt i was
in like real danger
at that point that my life could have
been in danger as well
ashley is one of thousands of children
placed into homes
that are unregulated that means they're
not inspected
but they are in demand because there's a
serious shortage
of places to house vulnerable children
today the education
secretary gavin williamson said these
places will be banned
for under-16s but he's under pressure to
do
more i have asked him to go further and
actually ban that provision for any
child under 18 because if they're
in care then those are the most
vulnerable children who need the most
support
there should be no instance where a
child
under the age of 18 who is in the care
of the state should be left
without proper supervision proper
support
and the regulation around it to ensure
that they're safeguarded against half
an investigation by sky news has
revealed the scale of the problem
we asked councils how many under 18s
they'd placed in unregulated homes
86 replied between january 2019 and the
end of 2020
they placed almost thousand children
there
we discovered that seventeen were sent
to hotels and bnbs
five were sent to holiday parks seven
were placed in
barges an independent review into the
children's social care
system is now underway it's expected to
take
18 months and it's headed by josh
mcallister
so the basic test for me is can we
create a system here
which better guarantees for every single
child growing up in england
safety stability and love is the sort of
bedrock of being able to go on and have
a successful future
when they look at you do they see
another guy coming along carrying out
review and publishing it in a big
fanfare
well can you look them in the eye and
promise them real change i can
um and they're going to have to judge me
quite rightly that they should
by the results of this review the
government say what happened to you
should never happen again why is it
important that they actually follow
through that promise
it is damaging to the people that are
placed in them
situations to point where i can just
destroy someone's life
the government's ban on unregulated
accommodation for under 16s
won't actually come into force until
september
that means thousands of children will be
placed in potentially unsafe homes
between now and then nick martin sky
news
well foreign office minister james
cleverley joins me now good morning to
you minister um
how was this ever allowed to happen
almost 10 000
children placed in unregulated
accommodation
well i think the the point that you made
from uh
gavin williamson is right that this is
now being
addressed uh it was terrible hearing the
situation uh that uh that young woman
went through
uh but the the government is addressing
this and um
as you say gavin william kevin
williamson has making uh has made a
statement on this
what what exactly is the government
proposing to to address this this
problem
well the i mean i can't really answer
the to the line that you've already
taken from
uh from the department it's it it's a
horrific situation that uh that that
young person went through we don't want
anyone to have to go through
something like that uh again um but the
uh let's say the government has made a
statement on that which you've got i
can't really add to that
the earliest that the the ban would
would come into force would be
uh in september why not act now because
we know that
young people are vulnerable and will be
subject
to this policy why wait until september
well as i say i mean you're asking me
for detail that
uh that i don't have at my uh my
fingertips
uh the the government has made a
statement on this policy
uh it's it's it's not always possible
for policy to be implemented
immediately if if
people need to be moved to other care
settings that needs to be arranged so
it's not possible to bring things in
immediately like that and as i say the
uh the government has made a statement
you read out the
statement made and and as i say i can't
really answer that
okay let's move on to um the handling of
the pandemic and we know that
the government is to to make an
announcement on monday
about the possible route out of of
lockdown
there is data that the government has
been waiting on
is that now where the the prime minister
and will it be published
well the the we've always set out
that we would assess the situation at
this point in mid-february
we would see a range of indicators
of how we are dealing with the
with the virus hospital admissions the r
rate amongst other things
that is being assessed at the moment and
the
uh the prime minister will be making
announcements uh
shortly about what we are able to do
next as we uh take the fight to uh to
the virus
and that announcement will be coming out
on monday and the
details underpinning those decisions
will also be discussed by
um by the government on monday so the
data will be
made available to to the public
well it's uh i can't guarantee that
every single data set will be
uh available at that point but we
have been we've been very very clear
that we have
gathered together a range of data sets
which will inform the
uh which will inform the decisions that
the uh the government is taking that's
happening at the moment the announcement
about the
implications what we're able to change
what we're able to
unlock and what we might may need still
to
restrict will be made available on
monday by the prime minister
uh the prime minister has said that he
wants this to be the the last
lockdown that's quite a a bold statement
to make with so many variables at play
well we do want it to be the last
lockdown that's what we're working
towards
we can see that the actions that we have
taken have had a positive effect
the vaccine rollout has been very very
successful that will all be having a
positive effect but ultimately
ultimately no one can predict with
complete
certainty what the vaccine will do
how it might evolve we are um
we are we are taking the right action we
are doing the right things
and we very very much hope that this
will be
the uh the last lockdown we can't give
complete 100 certainty because viruses
don't
work like that but we are doing we know
we're doing the right things we can see
it's having an effect
and um we we're assessing just how
that effectiveness is is playing out in
the real world so we can make the
announcement
uh early next week and in terms of
vaccines what can people expect by way
of priority there have been some reports
that
it will now be based on age and people
as young as as 40 could be offered
the vaccine within a number of weeks
rather than than key workers can you
tell us what what the direction of
travel is on that
well the prioritization of vaccinations
is is made as you know by an independent
body they take a number of factors into
consideration we are
and have been always guided by the
science
the the vaccine rollout is being very
very effective and that's
positive news i don't think it's useful
uh to speculate on what might happen
next i'm not a scientist we do listen to
the scientists
about the best way of ensuring that we
maximize the safety for as many people
as possible as quickly as possible
and that's what we will that's what will
always prioritize the the maximum safety
of british people
but people as you will appreciate do
want some form of clarity don't they
and they have clarity what i'm saying is
i i don't want to
make things less clear by speculating
the guidance is as it is
uh if the scientific evidence
points towards some changes we will
absolutely take that into consideration
but as it stands at the moment
the priority groups have been outlined
we are working
to get those groups vaccinated and we
are doing that
incredibly effectively and that is
the best way to ensure that collectively
we are all made safer you remember at
the beginning of the pandemic health
workers were crying out for uh ppe
it simply wasn't the available ppe we're
now hearing reports
of them saying that their lives are
being put at risk because the increased
risk hasn't been
uh kept up to date with what they've
been provided with and they're actually
saying that their lives are at risk
well the the safety of our frontline
workers whether in healthcare or in
other essential public services has
always been
a very very high priority for the
government in the outset of this
pandemic we moved as quickly as we were
able to to get additional ppe
one of the things that we did was to
ensure that the domestic production
capacity of ppe was increased
and we have now dramatically increased
our ability to produce ppe
uh here in the in the uk rather than
having to
buy it at the on the international stage
i'm very very pleased about that and the
uh our ability to provide ppe
now means that we can respond to changes
as they as they come about
what's the current situation on vaccine
passports and
the possibility of holidays for people
well i i get i completely get
how frustrating it is for people who
have uh as we all have had to live with
the restrictions that we've had through
the last 12 months or so
it is incredibly frustrating people do
want to have something positive to look
forward to and i completely understand a
very natural desire to think about
holidays to
to see friends to see family just to
relax at this stage
i'm not able we are not able to
uh to to to say what the situation will
be for holidays
uh this summer we are we are rolling out
this vaccination program
as quickly as uh as we are able to do
that very effectively
we have announced today our plans
to support vaccinations around the world
because none of us
are safe until all of us are safe and
that will mean that the the future
is much more positive than uh than
the recent past but we're not able to
give certainty sadly we're not able to
give certainty about when people will be
able to go on holidays
and giving vaccines uh internationally
sharing vaccines internationally at what
point
will the government decide that they're
able to to pass on surplus
well because of the decisions that we
took
uh much earlier in this pandemic about
our procurement
for uh for vaccines and we we sign
contracts with a range of providers
it means it is very highly likely that
we will have surplus
vaccines at this stage we don't know
exactly how many we don't know exactly
when that will be entirely dependent on
what
other vaccines come on stream but we
have made the commitment
to to do our international
duty by sharing our surplus vaccines
through kovacs we have been
very much in a leadership role with
regards to
making sure there is equitable access to
vaccinations
we were instrumental in hosting the
vaccine summit where 8.8 billion dollars
was committed
by the international community to fund
vaccines
for uh for the world and this is part of
our international duty to make sure that
yes we absolutely protect the british
people through our
excellent vaccination program but we
also make sure we do our part in keeping
the world safe as well
just quickly back to the um vaccine
passports which you didn't answer
the question um what is the definitive
line on that because they've been mixed
messages from
the governments and varying ministers
well now i think
i think the problem is that there's
there's been a lot of people
making assumptions about what a vaccine
passport
might be the last time i did a breakfast
media round i was asked about people
going on holiday
to greece and would they need a vaccine
passport for that and the point i was
trying to
make uh there and and the language
hasn't been clear in the questions that
have been asked by various people in the
media
is that countries may require
people to prove vaccinations if they are
going on holiday to those countries
that is a decision for those countries
those those
those hosting countries that is not a
british government
uh decision um then there's talk about
whether people will need to
approve a vaccine to be able to use you
know public transport or shops or go to
work that is a completely separate thing
uh and and there's there's unfortunately
i think there's been confusion between
the two
the vaccination program that we are
rolling out is to protect
all of us and that is moving at pace
that is being very effective
and we envisage that the positive
response the positive moves will enable
us to
ease restrictions over time
at the appropriate point in the
appropriate way and that is completely
separate to people's ability to go
overseas
and go on holiday because that would be
a decision for those countries like the
uk
james cleverley thank you very much for
speaking to us this morning
my correspondent rob powell is a
standing but i was listening through
that uh interview um and what was the
stand out for you are we clear on
vaccine passports or not i think it's
been a frustrating week both for
interviewers and
interviewees given the enormity of the
announcement due on monday
that i think most ministers that have
been on the airwaves this week haven't
had an awful lot to say
because it's all being announced on
monday and perhaps those decisions
haven't actually been
finalized yet i think on vaccine
passports we're perhaps not that much
further
further than we were before james
cleverley sort of suggesting that in
some way that questions being asked by
the media
weren't clear i think other people might
point out that his boss at the foreign
office dominic raab said on sunday
that they were looking into the
possibility of vaccine passports to get
into supermarkets
something that people in his team had to
hastily turn around and backtrack from
um in the minutes after he said it so
the message from the government hasn't
been clear on that
on vaccine passports but we do know that
work is going on
uh mainly to try and make sure that
people
can potentially travel abroad and have
the documentation they need to get
abroad
i think on everything else the message
from james cleverley has been very
similar to the message from all the
other ministers
we had on this week wait till monday yes
monday is the day
uh thanks very much for the moment see
you later on still to come
on the program at half past seven we're
joined by one of the professors
behind a new study which has found the
pfizer bayern tech vaccine to be 85
effective after the first dose
at 8 40 we'll take a look at the
challenges facing london fashion week
with the chair of the british fashion
council stephanie there
at 10 to nine speaking to a woman
training to swim from ireland to
scotland
by taking freezing cold dips in her
dustbin
stay at home coronavirus restrictions
will remain in place for the next three
weeks in wales
but the youngest children will begin to
return to school from monday morning
whilst his first minister mark drayford
has said cases of covet-19 in the
country
are at their lowest level since
september and one in three adults have
now been vaccinated
a review of the welsh restrictions in
march is also set to be announced
which could include a wider return to
schools and
colleges
the prime minister will promise to send
a surplus coronavirus vaccines to the
world's poorest countries
as we've been hearing from james
cleverley there boris johnson will make
the pledge at a virtual meeting of g7
leaders later today
the event will be president biden's
first international meeting to discuss
the global response to
the pandemic
latest figures show that 12 057
new confirmed cases of covid19 were
recorded
in the most recent 24-hour period
that's 10 lower than last thursday a
further 454 people have died within 28
days of testing positive
down 26 on last week
that brings the uk total to 119
387. 16.42 million first doses of the
vaccine
have now been administered
to guatemala now where three of its most
active volcanoes
are all erupting at the same time the
last time the phenomenon occurred was in
2018
when hundreds died after whole
communities were enveloped by gas
ash and rock sky news has visited
these communities living in the shadow
of two of the volcanoes
situated inland from the country's
pacific coast
balkan de fuego and vulcan pakaya are
active volcanoes
and they're a cause for concern to
authorities
they're found close to the city of
antigua guatemala from where our chief
correspondent
stuart ramsey sent this report
these eruptions are enormous and they're
regular vast plumes of steamer dash
pumped into the skies
guatemala is used to this it has over 30
active volcanoes
but three are simultaneously erupting
it's happened before sometimes with
deadly consequences
this is volcan fuego the volcano of fire
by night you understand its name
just 30 kilometers away pacquiao is
erupting as well
molten lava flows from its crater
streaming down the sides of the volcano
shrouded in steam pacquiao's peak boils
and bursts
a fiery warning of the potential for a
huge eruption
by daybreak the authorities allowed us
to trek to the closest monitoring point
near the peak it seems far away
but it's actually very near towering
above us
the noise of the volcanoes rumbling is
frankly terrifying
is it exploding
it's erupting 30 to 40 times a minute
when it gets to 80 a minute
the local experts warn a cataclysmic
event is possible
it's possible to monitor and predict an
eruption two or three days before
depending on the number of explosions
if there is more than an average of 80
to 100 explosions per minute it's a
warning a major eruption might be
imminent
whole communities live in the shadows of
these volcanoes
the grey ash steam and cloud-filled
skies hide fuego
that looms over them in 2018
hundreds died in an eruption that spewed
billions of tons of water sand and rock
onto the towns below fuego is
threatening them again point is these
communities and there's lots of them
around here actually on the volcano
are in incredibly vulnerable to
the lava it's flowed through here before
and obviously from
the gases that can come off a major
explosion
over 180 000 people live in these
communities
on the volcano and uh
most of them simply can't afford to
leave so they'll stay many say they'd
like to
but they just simply can't afford to and
they won't leave their homes
even those who have lived here their
whole lives seemed spooked
by the increased activity
lindy salan told us how the eruptions
are rocking their homes particularly at
night
when they get bigger
it explodes like a bomb at times the
windows and doors shake from the noise
that it makes
so to a degree you're stuck she said
that her family can't afford to leave
and even worse they'd be trapped by the
lava anyway
she said they'd have to head for higher
ground
on this side there are two or three
rivers so when something like this
happens
the lava flows into the river when the
time comes to leave
we can't because we're stuck here
there is a sense here that the
communities feel abandoned
they've nowhere to run when these
towering volcanoes explode there is no
place to hide
stuart ramsey sky news guatemala
let's take a look now at some of the
other stories making the headlines this
morning
it's reported a woman protester in
myanmar who was shot in the head last
week
has died the 28 year old was injured
during clashes with police and is the
first protester to have died since the
military seized power
earlier this month health workers have
called on the government to update the
advice on ppe
to reflect increased risks organizations
including the royal college of nursing
and the british medical association
say current measures to reduce the
airborne spread of the virus
are inadequate
more than two million people in the uk
have not received money back for flights
they were unable to board due to the
coronavirus pandemic
consumer group witch said some
travellers may not be entitled to a
refund if they're prevented from flying
due to restrictions or lockdowns
dolly parton has asked her home state of
tennessee not to build a statue in her
honor
lawmakers have been discussing a bill
for a statue of the country music star
at nashville state capitol government
building
in a statement dolly said given all that
is going on in the world i don't think
putting me on a pedestal
is appropriate at this time
nasa's mission to find signs of life on
mars has beamed back its first image
from the surface of the red planet
the perseverance rover touched down
safely following a treacherous seven
minute plunge
through the martian atmosphere and will
now spend two years traveling across the
planet
our science correspondent thomas more
reports
catch on confirmed
[Applause]
the seven minutes of terror of a martian
landing would have felt like a lifetime
in mission control
oh my god but perseverance survived its
perilous descent through the planet's
thin atmosphere
and within minutes was sending back
pictures of its new home
the rocky terrain seen through a still
dusty lens
we've been wondering where we're going
to land what are we going to see and
it's really great to see rocks you know
real geology right away so we're
extremely excited
perseverance landed in the jezreel
crater in the planet's northern
hemisphere
is 28 miles wide and 3.5 billion years
ago it's thought to have been
a lake fed by a river the rover will
search for signs of ancient life in clay
deposits in the river delta
and along the lake's shoreline this
british astrobiologist has a few
tiny fragments of a martian meteorite
that hit antarctica long ago
now he'll be helping to direct the rover
towards the crater's most promising
rocks
if conditions were the same on the early
earth and on early mars
then why on one planet and not the other
if
life is a natural consequence of the
right chemistry
the right raw materials and the right
conditions why not the rover will
analyze rock samples for organic
bio signatures and package up the most
promising pieces to be collected by
another rover in 2026 to be brought back
to earth
expensive but finding evidence of life
on another planet carries a high burden
of proof
one day we can make an announcement that
we have found life out there in the
universe
i think we'll blow people's socks off
because i think it just sort of
it means we're not alone the mission
carries a small helicopter that will
attempt the first powered flight on
another planet
and it will also be the first attempt to
generate oxygen from the carbon dioxide
rich atmosphere
that would make future human exploration
far easier
but for now it's a self-driving robot
that will be making a mark
on the martian surface thomas more sky
news
time now to take a look at the weather
for you and it certainly is a lot milder
it certainly felt wilder this morning am
i right
yeah it's generally looking mild for the
rest of this week we had a bit of a
cooler day yesterday but
the rest of the week we continue with
the southerly flow but we also continue
with the very wet and windy conditions
and there may be the risk of localized
flooding in parts of the west too
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so we're going to continue
with the mild conditions for the rest of
this
week in fact for some areas temperatures
could be in the mid to high
teens so it will feel spring-like indeed
but it won't feel very spring-like
across western areas currently this
morning outbreaks of heavy rain
over the west with very strong winds and
that rain will be moving its way a
little further eastwards this afternoon
clearing from
most of ireland and northern ireland
where it will become brighter and drier
later but there will be some heavy
showers there meanwhile
rain will affect much of scotland
northern and western parts of england
wales
and there will be heavy downpours across
these areas in fact over the next few
days there could be more than months
worth of rainfall for parts of the south
of wales and dartmoor
could lead to localized flooding and
patchy rain later across central and
eastern areas
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the prime minister is understood to be
expecting evidence on the impact of the
coronavirus vaccine program on hospital
admissions and deaths
ahead of setting out his road map out of
lockdown next week
earlier foreign office minister james
cleverley told this program the
government can't guarantee
this will be the last lockdown that it's
too early to plan summer holidays
we are taking the right action we are
doing the right
things and we very very much hope that
this will
be the uh the last lockdown
we can't give complete 100 certainty
because viruses don't work like that but
we are doing
we know we're doing the right things we
can see it's having an effect
and um we we're assessing just how
that effectiveness is is playing out in
the real world so we can make the
announcement
it is incredibly frustrating people do
want to have something positive to look
forward to and i completely understand a
very natural desire to think about
holidays to see friends to see family
just to relax
at this stage i'm not able we are not
able
to uh to to to say what the situation
will be for holidays
uh this summer
a new study into the efficacy of the
pfizer bind tech vaccine has found that
the jab is up to 85
effective after the first dose research
by the sheba medical center the largest
hospital in israel
assessed the effectiveness of the
injection among 7 000 of its health care
staff
and i'm joined now by professor erlesham
an expert in infectious diseases at
the hospital uh welcome to you um first
of all tell us
the detail of this this study what what
exactly did you find
during the months of january and early
february most of shiba health care
workers were vaccinated with the first
dose
and scheduled for the second dose and we
compared the vaccinated workers with the
unvaccinated
workers looking at the rates of positive
covet tests
and symptomatic disease and what we
really found is
by the third week after receiving the
first dose there was a sharp decline
both in infections
and in symptomatic disease which reached
85 percent
during days 15 to 28 after the first
dose
what was that a surprise in terms of
finding because the the
recommendation um that we're pursuing
in the uk now is that there will be a
a three-month delay between the first
and
the second vaccine does your finding
suggest that because of the efficacy as
85
after the first vaccine the policy being
pursued by the uk government
is perhaps the right course of action
well our study absolutely supports this
idea of vaccinating double the
population with a limited
amount of vaccine doses available
vaccinating twice the number of persons
and reaching a good enough effective
effectiveness of about
85 percent rather than vaccinating half
the number
with two doses even though effectiveness
is slightly higher
so that 85 percent is only after a
shortened period of time so only after
the
three weeks does it then follow that
there would still be that level of
efficacy
for a longer period of time i.e the
three months
we will not be able to study that in
israel because in israel the
recommendation is to provide a second
dose
after three weeks but these data i
expect will
continue to be gathered from countries
that do recommend a longer
interval between the two doses there's
no physiological immunologic reason to
think
that immunity drops sharply within a
month or two after the first dose to the
contrary we know
the the first dose is highly immunogenic
but we really have to wait for real-life
data to be gathered
but from what you know so far would it
suggest that the efficacy would remain
at that
level for an extended period of time
post
three weeks absolutely we're actually
seeing a slight trend of increase
during the fourth week uh even higher
protection
but then most workers did receive their
second dose sometime during that
fourth week in israel now we know israel
is under the spotlight
many have been looking to you because
it's been incredibly successful
um the rollout of the vaccine what is
the next stage for you and on the basis
of that successful rollout
will you then be addressing your issues
with restrictions
yeah roughly half of the country
population
either received the vaccine or have
recovered from kovid
and the next step is going to be
granting what we call a green badge
a certificate of being vaccinated or
recovered and allowing these
persons carrying the green badge to go
to sports events to cultural events to
hotels
swimming pools and and really resume
a normal form of living which is very
exciting and encouraging so what have
you seen in terms of
effects following the the vaccination of
of people in terms of
the infectious rate of the disease
well despite easing lockdown
restrictions we are seeing
a drop in the number positives which
fell by over a half
from the peak of the current wave we're
seeing a reduction in severe cases
reduction in proportion positive
and they are not which tells us how much
the disease is spreading is really
dropping and all these as i mentioned in
spite of easing lockdown so people are
meeting more gathering more
and we're not seeing more infections
what would your
advice be to the uk government in terms
of
easing restrictions coming out of
lockdown and the rollout in general of
the vaccine
based on your experiences well i would
say
once a substantial proportion of the
population at risk
is protected from severe disease then
this balance of lockdown which does have
health
challenges it does pose economic
challenges will need to be
balanced against protecting this
population at least
so i think slowly easing lockdown once a
a critical percentage like 80 percent of
atria's population is protected
would make sense okay professor alsham
thank you very much for sharing
expertise with us this morning thank you
thank you the texas senator
ted cruz has been forced to fly home
after he went on holiday
while the state was hit by extreme
weather at least 24 people have died and
thousands of people have been without
power
for days more than seven million people
have been told to boil their water
after extensive damage to pipelines adam
parsons reports
from texas this is ted cruz
senator for texas high-profile
republican
and now a very embarrassed man with his
state paralyzed by arctic weather
mr cruz decided to fly with his family
to the heat
of a mexican beach resort today he came
home
and admitted the trip had been a mistake
the moment i sat on the plane i
i began really second guessing that
decision and saying look
i i know why we're doing this but but
i've also got responsibilities and it
had been my intention
to be able to to work remotely to be on
the phone to be on internet to be
on zoom to be engaged but
i needed to be here he returned to a
state that is still struggling with
power cuts intermittent water supplies
and ice-bound roads
ted cruz is one of those loving or
hating figures in american politics and
there's no doubt this
trip to mexico is fuel for his critics
because while he's been away texas has
been
struggling with the after effects of the
extreme weather
in the city of plano volunteers are
handing out donations to residents who
still got no running water
much of texas is relying on this sort of
impromptu support
our systems haven't all worked out the
way we've needed them to
and so there's a lot of people that are
are hurting you know they didn't have
electricity they haven't had the heat
they've needed and then
now we've got people whose pipes are
bursting and they don't have access to
water
and so there's just been a bad collision
of a lot of things not working right and
so
plano is a great community there's a lot
of people who want to step up and help
and so it's
it's nice that we have people here who
just say how can i help my fellow
neighbor
as for mr cruz's trip to cancun we
couldn't find
anyone to stick up for him he should
have never gone in the first place
yes he can't be the one out fixing
turbines and salting the roads but he's
the one that can at least get people
here to fix things
you should have stayed in the united
states you annoyed with them
yeah i mean i would this would be nice
to go on vacation too
especially when it is you know it's so
cold but
the electricity is coming back the
weather is warming the ruinous ice will
soon be gone
but restoring ted cruz's reputation may
take longer
adam parsons sky news plano texas
still to come on sky news breakfast i'll
be discussing vaccine hesitancy with the
medical director of primary care for nhs
england
and nhs improvement
there are very many symptoms of both
uh acute covariate and also long
covering that people do need to know
about but
in this publication we highlighted uh
five that of particular interest because
they are common in the first few days
of the illness when people are most
infectious
and some of the other ones that we know
about
often can happen uh several days or
weeks
after the the initial period of
infection so
the the two key ones i think people
probably already know about
maybe don't realize that they are so
clearly linked to covid when it's
uh common are headache and
fatigue and the other one is sore throat
which people would normally
not expect to to think about with about
with covid and then you've got
the other one which we we see quite a
lot of is is diarrhea
and there's other ones you could add to
that list but we didn't for this paper
such as
muscle pains and of course they are in
addition to
the uh the three classic ones which are
the uh fever loss of uh smell or taste
and persistent uh cough and shortness of
breath so
i think what we're seeing is that if you
didn't have
those uh extra symptoms including your
list
and let's be most other countries do
you uh would miss about 30 percent
of cases that go on and have a positive
pcr test so one in three
people are probably being missed at the
moment with symptoms
and aren't being allowed to get a test
under the current rules
which sort of made sense at the
beginning of this pandemic
when we didn't have enough testing and
they weren't as good as some of the
other symptoms
but now we've got plenty of spare tests
it seems nonsense and i think we
really want to change the uh what the
rules and regulations
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
we help you understand the world with us
stuart ramsey sky news
[Music]
[Music]
now it's the start of london fashion
week and this year's uh will be
very different with lockdown forcing the
elite event online
and it's not only the pandemic that's
changing the fashion industry but
brexit too emma burchley reports
the first glimpse of the latest work by
designers like paul costello
would usually be preserved for those in
the front row at london fashion week
but like everything in recent times the
events had to adapt
instead the models have taken to the
catwalk in advance
and autumn winter collections for 2022
are being revealed in online videos for
all to see
but this year the industries had more to
contend with than just covid
in the form of brexit dips are coming
from germany
all of a sudden you don't have the right
size zip where you go you
you call your german supplier he says
yes i'll get her in the post
and and it either sits at heathrow
airport uh standstill
for two weeks and then the show's
already come and gone
nearly a hundred designers have embraced
the difficulties
to show their work over the next five
days it has been an incredibly
challenging year for the fashion
industry
i think disproportionately affected by
covid and then of course by brexit and
so
this moment of opportunity this uh not
any glimmer of light but it will be a
shining light of creativity is what we
all need to
lift us up and this year for the first
time
london fashion week is showing women's
wear and menswear in the same event
about time according to josephine jones
i think it heralds a new era of
inclusivity and fashion that
as the first trans designer to show on
the london fashion week schedule in 2019
i'm
thrilled about i mean i think it's
really exciting an idea of when shops
may finally reopen
is expected on monday and for many it
can't come too
soon it's estimated consumer spending on
fashion
has fallen by almost a third in the past
year
and it's expected that around a quarter
of a million people in the industry
will end up losing their jobs the
industry will revive
and paul's already thinking about
designs for fashion week in september
what's not clear is whether they'll be
revealed to an actual audience
or via a screen emma birchley sky news
central london
there's still widespread concern about a
reluctance amongst ethnic minority
communities to have the covid19
vaccine let's take a look at this advert
which heard last night to try to address
the issue
the covid19 vaccines have gone through
the same strict processes and
regulations
as other vaccines such as for measles
mumps
rubella and tb there is no chip or
tracker in the vaccine to keep watching
where you go
your mobile phone actually does a much
better job of that
pregnant women are not excluded from the
vaccine
but should discuss their case with the
doctor there's also
no evidence to suggest the vaccine
affects fertility
we're joining me now to discuss this is
the gp dr nikki cannani who's also
medical director of primary care for nhs
england
and nhs improvement uh welcome to good
morning
um first of all why do we think there is
this
reluctance what's the history behind
certain communities
being reluctant to take this covert jam
thank you julian can i just first of all
say you know our our vaccination teams
across the country
are doing an incredible job uh we're
over 14 million
first stages in england alone and people
are genuinely working day and night to
set up services
in lots of creative ways to tackle this
challenge
but you know um i i do think something
that it's at the core of this is a real
um concern about uh
you know can we trust the vaccine is it
safe and that's why this video is really
helpful because it helps to remind
people
that it is safe and effective that it
has been tested rigorously
and that when you get off of the vaccine
you should
take it and we really do need to keep
offering the vaccine
but also take lots of different ways to
reassure people so the video is just one
thing
translating our information is just one
thing the really key part is the local
community relationships
that allows community leaders and faith
leaders to help support vaccine uptake
with their own residents and local
population
but back to the original question why is
there this reservation in the first
place i think we've got
years you know possibly decades of uh
generational trauma where people
have been worried about um you know
vaccines being tested on them
people are worried about whether they
can trust the vaccine but
we know now um it's really clear that
the risk of covid
is much much greater than the risk of
the vaccine so the vaccine prevents
hospitalization and death covid does all
of those things and so
what we're on a real mission to do is to
make sure that when people are offered
the vaccine that they feel confident to
do so tell us a bit more about the
methods that you're employing to to get
people to come forward and take the
vaccine despite
the misinformation that they might have
heard
well you're absolutely right one of the
one of the key issues for us is
misinformation
and so that is one of the key things
that we have to tackle working with
social media companies to make sure that
we don't see
the misinformation that makes people
worry and doubt the vaccine and the
video picks up a few of those and you
saw those in the clip
but the other things that have been
really key is the local work we've got
over 200
pop-up places where you can get your
vaccination as well as our 1500
core vaccination sites and those pop-up
venues are in mosques and gurudwaras and
temples
and we've developed those with local
leaders so often it's the imam who talks
about
the vaccine after friday prayers and
then opens up their mosque to let people
to come in
to have their vaccine and we're
incredibly grateful for local leaders
for doing that
the other thing uh the other initiative
that's been great are vacci
taxis or vaccine buses again working
with the local community
to get a bus or a taxi right into the
heart of the community
to offer the vaccine from familiar
places and by familiar people
and that seems to be making the
difference but it will take some time
for some people to be confident so i
want people to remember that that
vaccine offer is an evergreen offer
it is always available so even if you've
said no previously
and you now decide to say yes we will we
will vaccinate you that vaccination
offer is for you
thank you very much for making that all
very clear dr nikki kanani thank you
good to speak to you this morning
let's see what's happening with the
weather now boy
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it's mild once again for
today
and for the rest of the week but also
staying unsettled for the rest of week
there's going to be a lot of wet weather
around particularly across parts of the
west
and especially so over the next few days
across parts of dartmoor and the south
of wales where
there will be the risk of localized
flooding there could be around a month's
worth of rainfall across these
areas over the next few days now
currently it's very wet across parts of
the west of the uk and island very
strong winds across these areas drier
further east
we'll see that rain shift its way a
little further eastwards this afternoon
across much of scotland northern and
western parts of england wales where
we're
going to see the heaviest of the
downpours across the west and there will
be some patchy rain later across parts
of the midlands
central southern and perhaps eastern
england but for most of the day across
the parts of the east of england
although it will be rather cloudy
and dull it will be mainly dry until
some patchy rain might
appear there later that rain as it
shifts its way further eastwards
means that we'll see brighter conditions
and drier as well across parts of
ireland and northern ireland but there
will be a line of heavy showers
spreading eastwards across these parts
as i mentioned very windy throughout
today and for the rest of the week
across parts the west
but it's a mild southerly flow so
staying mild
the weather sponsored by qatar airways